oh
la vie à emmener charles aznavour
jusqu'au bout des yvelines à montfort
l'amaury le chanteur franco-arménien
repose dans la sépulture familiale
depuis le 6 octobre 2018
de nombreux visiteurs sont venus se
recueillir auprès de leur idole ça
représente à peu près de 100 personnes
par semaine notamment l'office de
tourisme d'arménie le véritable ville de
torri d'arménie a organisé au point tant
d'écart pour venir voir rendre un
hommage à savoure sachant que c'était
quand même une idole en arménie et en
france en simulation et dans le monde
charles aznavour était quand même très
connu dans le monde entier les nombreux
touristes remplissent les commerces de
la place de l'église de la commune des
restaurants font découvert en plus cette
boulangerie a enregistré une hausse de
son chiffre d'affaires on a eu une
grosse période où beaucoup d'étrangers
aussi bon c'était quelqu'un qui était
énormément connu donc par conséquent
c'est un peu logique que les gens
viennent et l'appréciait quoi surtout
montfort l'amaury lieu de pèlerinage
musical à côté de charles aznavour il
est à la maison musée de maurice ravel
et ces journées organisées au mois
d'octobre avec le boléro qui résonne
encore
[Musique]
oui